978 in King Edward the martyr has been
successfully martyred Ethelred ii he's
younger brother who is better known as
Ethelred the unready succeeded him side
know about this name first there is no
evidence that this was used during
ethelred's lifetime and second it's
actually play on words
in Old English Ethelred means wise
counsel and oon red means bad counsel so
his name actually means wise counsel -
poorly counseled because as will become
evident he trusted the wrong people
so ascending the throne after your
mother probably orchestrated the
assassination of your predecessor is not
a very good place to start this was not
as the Reds only problem since many of
the nobles who had their lands given to
the church by a thurid's father King
Edgar wanted them back and many just
simply took them this place death the
red right in the middle of a conflict
between the church and the nobility
unfortunately for Ethelred an even
bigger threat to his kingdom re-emerged
during his reign the Vikings the Vikings
began raiding shortly after Ethelred
became king but this was small-scale
until the later 10th century when Viking
rate became significantly more deadly
the root of the change from small scale
to large comes from Denmark which at the
beginning of ethelred's reign was ruled
by Harald Bluetooth who also wrote
Norway Harald had professionalized the
danish army by the time he was deposed
by his son Sweyn Forkbeard in 1986 it
was an extremely potent force in 991
Ethelred signed a treaty with richard
the duke of normandy which stipulated
that neither would allow the vikings to
use each other's ports to resupply this
didn't do much to deter the vikings
since they launched their first major
attack against the anglo-saxons in the
same year they were met at maldor which
is here by the older man Brick Nath who
was defeated and his efforts were
immortalized in the Old English poem the
Battle of Mountain in response to the
defeat Ethelred was advised to pay the
Vikings off this technically works since
they did leave but the irony was that
since the Vikings could now simply turn
up and be paid a huge sum of money amend
the ethelred's Kingdom became a much
more valuable target so the sums paid to
the Vikings were absolutely massive
according to the anglo-saxon chronicle
the first tribute was 10,000 pounds of
silver or other things of equivalent
value the only reason that the English
Way was raised so much money was because
of how centralized the kingdom had
become over the previous century the
reforms had allowed the Kings officials
notably Shire Reeves to collect taxes
efficiently the idea to pay off the
Vikings came from the Archbishop of
Canterbury sidorak who himself had to
pay off the Vikings to prevent them from
burning down the cathedral at Canterbury
if the red spy
King trouble was compounded with the
problems he had with his nobility many
of the Viking raids were occurring in
lands which had only recently been added
to the kingdom and the royalties of said
landlords were still shaky to keep the
kingdom together Ethelred made many
donations of lands to the alderman from
outside Wessex making them much more
influential the Year 1002 saw two major
events the first was the Ethelred
married Richard of Normandy sister Emma
and this was the start of the close
relationship between the anglo-saxon
Kings and the Dukes of Normandy the
second was the st. Bryce's Day Massacre
this was an order given by a threat to
slaughter all of the Danes within his
kingdom on the 13th of November the fact
that this order was given implies that
there was a genuine terror felt over the
threat the Danes posed naturally this
order wasn't genuinely enforceable since
large waves of the kingdom were made up
of days but many massacres were carried
out and the loss of life was huge it is
likely that the invasion in 1003 by King
Sweyn Forkbeard was a response to the
massacre which may have taken the life
of his sister Swain landed in East
Anglia and sacked the city of Norwich
but the fighting against the English was
costly and so in 1005 he returned to
Denmark the next year he was back and
ransacked the south of the kingdom
before being bought off this time with
36,000 pounds Ethelred wanted to be
better prepare for future attacks from
the Vikings and so commissioned the
building of a large fleet of 300 ships
unfortunately for Ethelred the next year
there was a dispute between two Alderman
a certain a Adric stray owner of Mercy
er and another called wolf naath
things got out of hand wolf enough stole
20 ships a Adric followed with 80 ran
them ashore and wolf knife ended up
burning them thus the new Navy due to a
petty dispute was shrunk by a third
meaning it wouldn't be able to stop a
Viking fleet if one turned up well one
did turn up soon after led not by Swain
but by thorkild the tool thorkil and his
men ravaged many parts of the country
including Oxford in 1011 Thoko laid
siege to Canterbury and seized the city
along with the archbishop there Alf heah
who he tried to ransom Elvia refused to
be ransomed and so some of Thoreau's men
murdered him thorkil like most of the
vikings at this time was a Christian and
was either disgusted with the murder or
believed he could no longer control his
men and so took the troops most loyal to
him and defected to fight for Ethelred
the Viking invasions overshadowed most
of ethelred's reign but he was
responsible for continuing
administrative reform and issuing laws
which he upheld strictly very strictly
if the Reds most famous law code is
known as the Wantage code which notably
set up a local body of twelve vanes who
preside over trials and decide on a
charge man's innocence or guilt some
consider this to be the origin of the
jury but be aware that many dispute this
reforms aside ethelred's main concern
was still the Vikings and in 1013 Sweyn
Forkbeard returned many of the old areas
of the Danelaw accepted Swain as their
King almost immediately and by the end
of the year f the rest had fled to
Normandy in Swain was now the king of
the English Norway and Denmark Swain
thus began his long and prosperous reign
which lasted for five whole weeks before
he died the nobles negotiated for
Ethelred to return providing he abided
by certain rules and was a better ruler
the Danish army weren't going to allow
this and they declared Swain son Knut as
King Ethelred managed to drive connote
away fairly quickly but he returned in
1015 with a much larger army at the red
Sun Edmond who fought most of the
battles against Knut was essentially an
open rebellion against his father and
was in control of a sizeable portion of
the kingdom to make matters worse the
elderman the Adric of Mercia betrayed
Ethelred and joined Knut at the red tide
in April 1016 and his son was declared
king however after many losses Edmond
agreed to divide the kingdom between
himself and Knut but this didn't last as
Edmund died in November of the same year
thus could not receive the entire
kingdom and was the first monarch to tie
to himself as the king of England as
opposed to the title used by his
anglo-saxon predecessors King of the
English so Knut his most famous for
commanding the tide to stop crashing on
the shores of England for this he's
often portrayed as being a bit mad but
in fact it was a pious act and was to
show that even a Kings power pales in
comparison to God's so soon after he
became King Canute took the liberty of
murdering any English noble he didn't
like such as a a trick presumably
because of the whole betraying his
previous king thingg connect also raised
a colossal amount of money to pay off
the army which had won him the throne
which placed the kingdom under further
strain this strain is evidenced by the
fact that also in turn 18 the Scottish
invaded and managed to seize all of this
territory
soon after this can its older brother
Harold died and Knut inherited Denmark
after gaining Denmark connote had to
balance the needs of each of his
kingdoms and as his reign progressed he
spent more and more time in Denmark
during his first trip there cannot sent
a letter addressed to the English people
in which he declares that he will be a
just ruler but importantly he stated
that I went myself with the men who
accompanied me to Denmark and I have
taken measures so that never henceforth
shall hostility reach you from there as
long as you support me rightly and as
long as my life lasts so Knut was off
during the English peace against the
Vikings which was something England had
not had in many decades
Konoe also made a show of continuity by
first marrying ethelred's widow Emma of
Normandy although side note he actually
had two wives the second being a mercy
and lady called elf kethu alongside
marrying the widowed Queen could not
continue to use the laws of the previous
anglo-saxon Kings most notably those of
Edgar this doesn't mean that he didn't
change the way the kingdom was run
however Knut divided the kingdom into
four elders which would be run by his
trusted Earl's the Odom's were Wessex
Murcia Northumbria and East Anglia
initially Wessex which held England's
capital of Winchester was directly under
conduct rule but towards the end of his
reign in the ten thirty s cannot
appointed an Englishman could Godwin as
the Earl of Wessex
one major legacy of the division of
England into Odom's was that it
concentrated land and wealth into the
hands of very few people and a weak King
could potentially be challenged by one
of his own spoiler alert
this happens another change was that
connote established a group of
bodyguards called house cows who also
acted as the king's emissaries and
importantly were very expensive to
maintain since there were several
thousand of them in 1028 could not also
managed to gain Norway most weeks
returning up off the coast with a large
combined Anglo Danish Navy and looking a
bit scary in 1035 canook died leaving
the succession open to multiple
potential heirs Knut had wanted the son
he'd had with Queen Emma harthacnut to
succeed him but Harlequin it was busy in
Denmark fighting a rebellion to make
things more complicated Canucks son from
his first marriage Harald better known
as Harald Herefords the only potential
heir in England to size formed
concerning who should succeed Knut can
its first wife Alf Kieffer when the oohs
of Mercia and Northumbria favoured
Harald whereas Godwin the Earl of Wessex
the Archbishop of Canterbury in Queen
Emma favored harthacnut
the fact that women like Emma and elf
Gifu were extremely influential was down
to the culture of anglo-saxon England in
other European societies women had
significantly less power and rights than
in anglo-saxon England this does not
mean the women were seen as equal since
they absolutely were not but unlike
other kingdoms women could own inherit
and dispose of property which meant that
they could also be patrons they could
act as witnesses for trials and charters
and if there were victims of crimes the
compensation for them was the same as
men Oh God win an Emer eventually
realised that hard the Connaught wasn't
going to show and so accept it Harald as
their King for many of the nobles the
return of an English King would mean
that they were open to invasion by the
Vikings again which was expensive
in fact the payment of tribute to the
Vikings known as the guild was
europe's only general land tax which
applied to every one peasant a nobler
like which shows how centralized the
government was and how afraid of the
Vikings they were in 1037 Herod was
coronated as king but his reign for the
most part was uneventful and it is
believed that his mother was the real
power behind the throne Harold died in
1040 in the nobles of England invited
harthacnut to become king which he did
but not after arriving with an army just
to be sure
this army much like Canute's needed
paying so more geld was raised harvick
on a train was very short and he died in
1042 but it's important to remember that
that was common since of the 12 Kings
who ruled United England up until this
point eight ruled for less than a decade
and six died under the age of 30 Harbor
connote was the last Scandinavian to
rule England to mark the end of the
Royal House of Denmark and the return of
the Royal House of Wessex
I hope you enjoyed this episode and
thank you for watching if you'd like to
know more there are some book
recommendations in the description
you